well let's make a deal was a popular
show back in the day contestants could
go on this game show and maybe go home
with the car of their dreams first of
all the game show host was a very famous
guy named Monty Hall and Monty would
come on to the show and he would have
three doors and a contestant that's you
would come on to the show Monty would
give you the chance to choose door
number one door number two or door
number three now behind one of those
doors only one was your dream flash car
bright red sports car very fast it was
awesome and behind the other two doors
were socks that was let's make a deal
word for something that you don't really
want so you had looks like a one in
three chance of getting your dream car
so suppose you pick door number one and
Monty would then do the same thing every
week he would go over to the two doors
you didn't pick two and three and he
would open one of them let's suppose he
opened door number two and the door that
Monty opened would always have behind it
a zombie knew well he knows everything
right he's the game show host and then
Monty looked at you in the face and say
do you like door number one or do you
want to switch there's only one thing to
switch to in this case it's door number
three are you gonna stay with your
choice or are you gonna make that leap
to something different and very often
contestants would stand there agonized
right so they've got some new
information which stick or switch well a
remarkable thing about this problem
simple as it is is that it is sparked
just endless debate in the time of the
show I don't recall anybody ever saying
there was a dedicated strategy that you
should always follow but in fact there
is a dedicated strategy should follow
you should pick door number three that's
the answer you should switch you should
switch every time and that will do the
best for you over the long run so there
is a one-third chance that the car is
behind the door you picked initially
that means there must be a 2/3 chance
much greater twice as big that the car
somewhere else and since we know that
somewhere else cannot be door number two
because Monty showed us that it's got to
be over here so this is what you should
choose you should switch twice as likely
to have the car behind the door that you
didn't pick as the door that you did 2/3
probability to a 1/3 probability now if
you switch are you guaranteed to win
absolutely not but if you play this game
over and over again on average you will
win 2/3 of the time so switches your
strategy and you can't beat it one thing
that you might say is that the initial
2/3 chance that the car was behind door
number two and door number 3 got
concentrated behind the door that Monty
did not open that's effectively what's
happening that's intuitively what's
happening and that in fact is what the
mathematics shows is happening now there
is a way to see that in kind of a more
grand way if we imagine not having three
doors but we imagine having a hundred
doors and let's imagine that we're
playing the same kind of game we have
Monty over here he is going to give you
an opportunity to pick a door and your
dream flash cards behind one of these
hundred doors but there are 99 Sonic's
all behind the other doors now what is
it that you're going to do well you're
going to pick a door say again you pick
door number one now you're feeling a
little bit different than you might have
felt in the case where there were three
doors because there you thought wow I've
got a one in three chance here you're
thinking I've got a 100 chance I'm not
gonna get that car it's not behind door
number one it's probably behind one of
the other 99 doors what Monty does is he
opens 98 of those 99 doors he shows you
98 zonk's and he asked you now do you
want to switch well maybe just because
of the sheer numbers this thing is a
little clearer you know that there was
ninety-nine out of a hundred chance that
the car was over here and now the only
door you're left with after mom
shows you all those oxes d'Orsay number
37 and you're thinking this is no good
this is no good all those doors are no
good do I want to stay with one or do I
want to stay with 37 you can sort of
almost feel the concentration of that 99
percent going behind door number 37 and
so you switch over here and very likely
you're gonna get that car and drive away
I love you car door well thank you that
makes more sense doesn't it suddenly it
seems like a no-brainer it does seem
like a no-brainer but in fact when it's
on a smaller scale maybe just because
1/3 and 2/3 are a whole lot closer to
each other than one in a hundred and
ninety-nine and a hundred that the the
point is is obscured
x and y is the probability of x given
that y happens given that you know you
open door number two what's the
probability of the cars there times the
probability of Y happening by itself